chaque matin depuis une semaine et demie
c'est la même routine pour marie-eve une
enseignante de 4e annick elle prend sa
voiture et s'en va à montréal mais
rejoint les 26 élèves mais avec
plusieurs milliers d'autres matin c'est
ici dans ce petit studio dans cette
salle de classe virtuelle qu'elles
enseignent tous les avant midi de 8h15 à
12h 30
elle donne des cours de mathématiques ou
de français diffusée en direct sur
youtube pour chaque niveau du primaire
qu'on fait justement de la révision veut
pas des nouveaux des nouveaux acquis
nécessairement pour justement arriver là
avec tous les élèves d'un même siècle
demain et scolaires retrouve justement
l'école au même niveau
chaque classe dure environ une trentaine
de minutes
on vise à rejoindre les enfants qui ont
peut-être pas le support à la maison
loin d'être bien encadré d'être
supporter dans leurs études c'est la
première chose
l'autre chose en a un la crise pourrait
apporter justement là une perte de
motivation scolaire mythe chocolat avec
sa personnalité coloris six talents de
pédagogue
le nombre d'élèves qu'ils l'écoutent ne
cesse d'augmenter mercredi ils étaient
environ 10000 à la suivre en direct on a
déjà de partout qui nous écoutent de la
nouvelle écosse du nouveau brunswick
beaucoup au québec où civile les paras
se sont tellement aidés se sont appuyés
dans cette situation-là la haute ville
en ontario amy rose écoutent
quotidiennement la classe de marie ève
pour ses parents c'est un soulagement
c'est rassurant avec le télétravail de
mon conjoint et moi qui est infirmière à
l'hôpital
j'avais besoin quelque chose qu'ils
étaient capables d'accéder d'elle-même
n'y avait pas besoin d'avoir un parent à
côté d'elle tf1 depuis une semaine et
demie marie-eve a reçu 4000 courriel et
ses capsules vidéos ont été vues 265
mille fois et je vous avoue le conte une
grosse dose d'amour que je m'attendais
pas et j'ai l'impression pas partie même
de leur famille fait que je faisais que
je comme leur nouvelle prof temporaire
en blafard
ah ah les classes virtuelles de
marie-eve doit se poursuivre pour encore
au moins trois semaines ici j'en fais
les premiers en réseau au canada
montréal